[Musique]
ce moment du 9ème siècle et le moment se
met en place à l'échelle internationale
un système de division du travail
d'inégalité de domination d'abord avec
le système esclavagiste fric domination
coloniale violence thomas piketty
bonsoir merci de nous consacrer les
prochaines minutes ce soir bonsoir
depuis le début de la pandémie les
gouvernements les banques centrales ont
injecté des milliers de milliards de
dollars pour financer les programmes de
soutien un peu partout dans le monde
puis on peut avoir l'impression que ce
sont des interventions qui aide les gens
qui viennent réduire les inégalités mais
j'ai le goût de vous demander d'abord
est ce que c'est vraiment le cas alors
qu'on se dit qu'il vend tuellement
faudra peut-être payé la facture
certains s'inquiètent de hausse de
tarifs ou de taxes ou d'impôts
éventuellement oui et puis vous savez
aussi tout s'est tu
toute cette création monétaire de la
part des banques centrales parfois ça
peut aussi contribuer à enrichir les
plus riches c'est à dire que ça depuis
2008 c'est un peu une des limites de c2c
politique de création monétaire c'est
que ça n'a pas toujours bénéficié
forcément aux plus modestes c'est à dire
que vous vous achetez banque centrale
beaucoup d'actifs financiers auprès
auprès de banques et ça peut contribuer
à faire monter les cours boursiers a
fait remonter aussi les prêts
immobiliers
donc pour ceux qui ont les moyens
d'emprunter qui ont capacité d'emprunt
suffisamment importante et qui ont les
expertises les galops fiscal aux
financières pour emprunter parfois 0% et
puis investir dans les bons actifs qui
vont donc prêt à monter ça peut être une
source d'enrichissement pour les
personnes plus une plus modeste pour
cent de taux d'intérêt sur les prêts
d'epargne s'est passé pas forcément
c'est forcément une super noël donc
toute cette politique monétaire elle a
aussi contribué à accroître l'inégalité
d'aider des rendements du capital
obtenus par différents niveaux de
portefeuilles financiers différents
niveaux de patrimoine
et donc d'à côté on règle le problème de
la dette publique mais de l'autre on en
crée un autre problème en contribuant à
exacerber les des inégalités de
absolument de patrimoine donc c'est
passé et est ce que vous diriez que la
hausse boursière qu'on connaît en 2020
présentement pendant que le chômage
demeure quand même élevé que les
restrictions demeurent toujours en place
et en vigueur en bien des endroits
est ce que cette hausse boursière pour
vous c'est un indicateur majeur que les
écarts de revenus de patrimoine continue
de grandir
ben je oui je pense que la politique
monétaire a contribué à doper les cours
boursiers l'écho immobilier dans une
certaine mesure tout ça contribue à
enrichir les plus riches et je pense
qu'il faudrait que cette situation
monétaire souhaite davantage utilisé
pour raison pour augmenter les salaires
des infirmières ou des enseignants créer
plus d'emplois dans dans la santé dans
l'éducation alors à la fin des fins si
on fait beaucoup de sa salle on va sans
doute finir par déplacer l'inflation qui
est actuellement sur les prix des actifs
les concours chez les corps immobilier
voilà la déplacer sur les prix et les
salaires et à un moment il faudra
s'arrêter si on atteint 3 4% d'inflation
sur les primes et salaires il faut vous
le voyez bien qu'on en est très loin
aujourd'hui on a une inflation très
faible et 10 en fait où on ferait mieux
dans un premier temps d'essayer de re
reporter les usages de cette création
monétaire sur des choses qui sont en
plus plus utile parce que tous ces
salaires dans l'éducation dans la santé
sont souvent trop faible il faudrait
investir davantage dans l'environnement
il ya beaucoup d'emplois créés sur la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments
donc voilà il faudrait mieux déplacer
cette création monétaire pour ces
investissements utiles il dit ensuite
alors le jour où on aura fait ça et
qu'on aurait commencera à voir un peu un
peu trop d'inflation j'aurais prix et
des salaires pourrait il faudrait
arrêter et évidemment la création
monétaire est là dans ce cas là oui on
en viendrait à la question des impôts
parce que à la fin pour rembourser les
dettes et pour financer des dépenses
sociales
il faut un système fiscal et vous
parlait déjà dans le milieu de la santé
dans votre ouvrage capital et idéologies
vous démontrer combien au fil du temps
on a mis en place un système économique
dans l'organisation du travail qui
s'appuie beaucoup sur l'île sur de
fortes inégalités
est ce que c'est encore le cas
aujourd'hui et est ce que la crise la
coved 19 révèle encore un système basé
sur des inégalités oui c'est sûr que
l'épidémie a révélé donc dans un certain
nombre de cas toute la violence des
inégalités de nos sociétés c'est à dire
que les personnes qui avaient une grande
maison de campagne et des réserves
financières devant eux bon finalement le
confinement
c'est le pire ennemi c'est pas forcément
ces progrès social pour des personnes
qui sont dans un logement qui nous
recevons pas logement du tout et surtout
pour ceux qui sont dans un statut très
précaire du point de vue du travail des
emplois fragmenté qui sont keith aux
alentours entrepreneurs comme on a vu
beaucoup en france se développer ces
dernières années il n'y a pas de système
d'allocation chômage de chômage partiel
et là on est dans des situations
vraiment très compliqué pour un pour
payer son loyer
oui cette épidémie révèle toute la
violence de ces de ces inégalités
sociales et aussi le manque
d'investissement dans les hôpitaux dont
la santé qu'on a eu depuis de trop
nombreuses années et même chez nous on a
fait appel à des gens qui sont en
attente
peut-être en france également qui sont
en attente d'être d'avoir un état
régulariser dans la société
on les a mis au front les amis dans le
secteur de la santé et mêmes exposées
directement en première ligne au virus
oui alors la situation je pensais encore
pire de ce point de vue là en europe et
en france où on a une politique
migratoire qui est totalement totalement
incohérente et dramatique se dire que
d'un côté on est on est bien content de
faire appel aux migrants dans certains
secteurs et
de l'autre on laisse des personnes dans
des situations juridiques complètement à
certaines vous savez même bien il ya un
campement d'exil et là dans le nord de
paris à saint denis qui a été évacuée la
nuit la nuit dernière il ya plus de 1500
personnes qui vivaient dans des
conditions invraissemblables on
soustrait à la turquie raju dire
l'europe sous traite à la turquie le
fait d'avoir plusieurs millions de
migrants dans des camps en turquie dans
des conditions déplorables
tout ça tout ça est vraiment triste
venant de pays qui en fait ont les
moyens ont le besoin une main et ont les
moyens économiques et financiers de
d'intégrer d'accueillir des ddpp des
populations qui par rapport à la taille
de l'union européenne 500 millions
d'habitants les les
les chiffres dont on parle de migrants
sont beaucoup plus son fils est très
très faible et doit donc voilà on
construit mais je pense ça participe du
fait que l'on s'interdit trop souvent dû
réfléchir à un autre système économique
on a un peu fermé la discussion sur
différents systèmes économiques
possibles ce qui contribue aussi parfois
cela ce déplacement du conflit politique
derrière des questions vers des postures
nationalise des replis identitaires qui
empêche de régler de régler des
problèmes qui est un qui pourraient
l'être et devrait naître dernier point
est un monsieur basket si ce soir jamais
un président en exercice n'a eu autant
d'appuis lors d'une élection que donald
trump
même s'il n'a pas gagné il a quand même
obtenu plus de 73 millions de votes
est-ce que ce résultat selon vous doit
encore être interprétée comme étant
celui d'une colère face aux face aux
inégalités socio économique aux états
unis et un rejet toujours de la
mondialisation
oui je pense que le parti démocrate aux
états unis doit doit s'interroger sur sa
capacité à
à inspirer la confiance à tout un
électorat populaire qui autrefois voter
pour le parti démocrate s'est dit
confiant que le parti démocrate aux
états unis dans les années 50 60 70
parvenait à regrouper des classes
populaires issus de toutes les origines
blanche ou noire
grâce à des politiques menées depuis
l'époque du new deal qui finalement
rassemblé des personnes d'origines
différentes autour de politique et d'un
programme de réduction des inégalités
qui finalement était plus important que
les différences entre ces personnes
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation
très différente ou en fait le parti des
démocrates continuent de susciter la
confiance des classes populaires noirs
ou latinos issus des minorités mais par
contre au sein de l'électorat blanc qui
représente quand même encore 70% de
l'électorat
c'est le contraire c'est à dire que les
électeurs qui ont les plus bas salaires
les plus bas niveaux dit ont tendance à
voter pour traille et le parti démocrate
concentre ses soutiens sur plutôt les
plus diplômés ils ont légué miam la
mondialisation et ça c'est un changement
complet mais si vous comparez l'élection
de 2001 avec l'élection de 1960 kennedy
avait battu nixon de très peu dans une
élection très serrée
à l'époque au sein de l'électorat blanc
qui vont à l'époque était 4e en 10 %
blake droit c'était vraiment les moins
diplômés les plus bas salaires les plus
bas revenus qui votait qu'elle ait dit
qu'il voter démocrate aujourd'hui
environ 60 ans ça s'est complètement
transformé et donc quelle est la
solution
je pense que ça va prendre très
longtemps et il faut s'orienter dans
cette direction pour que le parti
démocrate parviennent à convaincre cet
électorat que face à la mondialisation
face à la montée des inégalités
il a de meilleures solutions à proposer
que le discours nationaliste et parfois
xénophobe du parti républicain qui n'est
évidemment pas la solution mais en même
temps à un moment il faut se dire là
pourquoi le parti démocrate n'arrive pas
à proposer des solutions que
convaincante et ce c'est un peu facile
de dire voilà ceux des lycées la troupe
des électeurs qui sont racistes on peut
rien y faire et je trouve que ça il est
vraiment temps de s'interroger là dessus
et 2
changer le rapproche le programme qui
est qui est proposé absolument très
intéressant c'est le temps que nous
avons ensemble ce soir mais je veux
simplement signaler que vous disiez
récemment dans le monde que grâce au
travail de 150 chercheurs du monde
entier vous avez maintenant accès à des
données sur les inégalités dans 173 pays
97% de la population
votre ouvrage capital et idéologies se
lit très bien à ceux qui veulent prendre
le temps de faire c'est quand même plus
de 1200 pages très détaillée très
intéressant thomas piketty
merci beaucoup merci merci à vous